I'd go light the first time that's it
you know there are old pharmacologists
and bold pharmacologists but there are
no old bowls pharmacology
[Music]
don't follow following is a is a
tasteless position to find yourself in
pets follow vice presidents follow and
bad acts follow so you know why follow
all of all of these gurus geishas
Roshi's and Rishi's are simply flim-flam
artists they've had thousands of years
to get these cons together and run them
on you believe me I know I'm a
recovering Catholic you have to fight
your way free of the leaf and then do
not follow just to show I'm really one
of the game I mean I Here I am there are
200 people here whatever and I do this
all the time and I have not so far as I
can tell been able to launch an
avalanche of DMT I'm trying do I have to
put in any more plainly
is there a chemist in the house who will
go home and make this stuff so that we
can find our way there or grow the plant
or go to South America or get with lucid
dreaming and behavioral modification or
explore the outer edges of orgasm which
I think has something to do with the
empty and probably runs on it somehow we
need to Beach this whale so I got it out
to roll the evenings joint and and I was
fumbling with it and I got this thing
lit and this little this little crumb
was a little burning thing fell on the
floor
and I lifted it up and smelled it and
the transubstantiation had occurred it
was you know like mazar-e-sharif triple
a Red Lion hashish of some sort and I
know hashish I and here we were in the
center of the Amazon in this hunt and
this pouring rain and I could tell that
it was the good it was the good [ __ ]
actually manifest so some people can't
tell whether I'm half shaman half
scientist they probably the answer is
simply half bait the fact that a human
being can feel 50 micrograms of a
compound is like a miracle I mean to
give you an analogy so you can
understand that that's like having one
red ant tear down the Empire State
Building in 30 minutes I mean that
that's what it looks like when 50 gamma
of lfd anterior body
because there's something about the anal
retentive primate mind that we want to
button it down you know and say well
it's this or it's that with no sense of
irony no sense of scale no
tongue-in-cheek approach at all I mean
if you met a termite who aspired to
understand the cosmic workings of the
universe you would just roll your eyes
at such a naive misunderstanding of
one's own position in the cosmos well do
you think we stand so far from where the
termite stands that our musings about
how the cosmos works are carrying much
force I don't I don't think so I don't
know what the number is they keep
pushing it up but they say thirty five
percent of the American public believe
flying saucers are real well now first
of all are we being asked to believe
that thirty five percent of the American
public can carry on a coherent
discussion of the concept real as real
as what as real as Madonna's talents as
real as Clinton's integrity how real are
the UFOs culture is a con game designed
to bewilder you for thirty five to forty
years and then if by some miracle you
can outlive that span of time a strange
realization will begin to dawn as you
sit at the poker table you'll realize
this is this is a bunch of crap I've
been had
well up until very recently only a very
few people in any society lived into
those ages and then that was called
wisdom I said you know he just sits on
his porch and rocks and occasionally
chuckles I was in a restaurant in Malibu
with Bob chartoff and Lou
Carlino who some of you know bunch of
fancy Hollywood type people and there
was this French producer there this
woman and she and I had been seated
together at dinner and she said you see
zedzee mushroom speaks to you but I
don't understand how this can be what do
you mean it speaks to you and I see in
and ralph abraham was there too and I in
my sincere way said well it's like the
parts Tiger played in the pawnbroker it
just and at that moment
Steiger stops by the table to shake
hands with everybody there and I'm like
true story true story and Ralph who's
watched this whole thing go down leans
across the table to me and says what
this proves is the mushroom can reach
into our world no matter where we are
and shake the bars
[Music]
so some people can't tell whether I'm
half shaman half scientist I think
probably the answer is simply half BAE
[Laughter]